anne et puis surtout la victoire de
nancy en coupe de france de football
il a suffi d'un petit but un coup de
pied devinette qui de platini bien sûr
en début de deuxième mi temps et pour la
première fois de son histoire l'as nancy
lorraine gagne la coupe de france en
battant nice partent à 0 et par la même
occasion nancy jouera l'an prochain à la
coupe d'europe des vainqueurs de coupes
pourtant thierry rolland ce soir au parc
des princes le match n'a pas été de très
grande qualité non comme souvent vous
savez on attendait monts et merveilles
de cette finale entre deux équipes
offensives nice et nancy
et puis la montagne un peu accouché
d'une souris peut être les deux équipes
se craignent et elle l'une et l'autre et
elles ont eu du mal à se libérer de
l'emprise de ce match pour les
conditions atmosphériques étaient bonnes
il ne faisait pas chaud car d'habitude
ou au moment où se dispute la finale de
la coupe il fait souvent chaud au parc
des princes bref les conditions étaient
requises pour avoir un beau match de
football et ça n'a pas été tout à fait
le cas je vous propose de regarder les
phases principales de cette rencontre
qui avait tout de même attiré près de 48
mille spectateurs le parc des princes
était comble un parc des princes du
reste surtout occupés par des supporters
de l'as nancy lorraine que c'est une
vérité de la palice
nancy est plus près de paris et que nice
les niçois sous leurs couleurs
habituelles a pas que les premiers faut
dire que le début du match et bangui
covic pacifier un bon tir que moutier a
beaucoup de peine à repousser et les
niçois commettent une erreur
sous l'impulsion de guillou leur meneur
de jeu de me jouer qu'avec deux
attaquants en pointe c'est-à-dire
sanchez et bjekovic deux attaquants
évidemment très esseulé ils obtiennent
quand même de bonnes occasions et
moutier
pour intervenir ce sont les deux
occasions les plus sérieuses l'outil
devant une nouvelle fois sortir devant
jours pour boucher l'angle de tir
jean michel moutier avait été le héros
de la demi-finale contre sochaux à
l'occasion du match aller et puis en
début de deuxième mi temps michel
platini appelle le ballon au centre de
la défense publié le videur et il frappe
le poteau
la balle pénètre à l'intérieur du but de
baratelli qui n'appuie excusé le moindre
geste fort que le ballon était
totalement hors de sa portée
ce sera pour le sait maintenant le seul
but de la partie
un but qui vaut de l'or puisqu'il permet
à l'as nancy lorraine un club vieux
d'une dizaine d'années à peine de
remporter pour la première fois la coupe
de france une épreuve qu'il offrait
recherché loyer de la réussite car la
balle frappe le montant du poteau mais
michel platini précisera après que à son
avis sur la fin du match l'équipe de
nancy méritait la victoire il faut dire
que ce but libère les joueurs de nancy
olivier rouyer se montre dangereux à
plusieurs reprises ici chevelle réussi
l'informatique reprise qui passe de peu
au dessus il y aura deux autres actions
dangereuses qui suivront cette reprise
de chevelle et olivier rouyer à deux
reprises sera tout près de marquer le
deuxième but comme ici où la balle
rebondit sur le poteau détournée qu'elle
a été par le gardien de but baratelli
ont finalement être dégagée sur la ligne
par un défenseur niçois
nice a un peu déçu il faut bien le dire
le ballon me réveille kg sur balles en
répondant que si vous voulez ça a peu de
chance non mairie fera pas du match
nous sommes déçus disait 'je mais les
nancéens eux n'y sont pour rien et c'est
un michel platini radieux capitaine de
l'as nancy lorraine qui brandit à la
foule
la première coupe de france gagnée dans
l'histoire de son club qui avait été
deux fois finaliste mais sous le nom de
football club de nancy il ya une
vingtaine d'années je suis valéry
giscard d'estaing a félicité leur
capitaine qu'il connaît bien puisqu'il
avait déjà rencontré en lorraine et
alayli une thierry est ce que michel
platini les prochaines jours encore à
nancy jouera donc la coupe d'europe
absolument nous lui avons posé la
question dans les vestiaires des
vestiaires euphorique vous l'imaginez
bien et michel fatigue et terminera son
contrat à l'as nancy lorraine il doit
jouer encore pendant un an donc il sera
à la tête de l'as nancy lorraine qui
sera renforcée nous a dit son entraîneur
antoine godin ne sait pas encore par qui
sait bientôt mais qui sera renforcé pour
représenter la france dignement dans la
coupe d'europe des vainqueurs de ces
présidents de la république